رحبوا بالعميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي معنا من بيروت عميد الياس
حنا كيف تقيم من الناحيه العسكريه وضع
القوات الروسيه وهم موجودون الان من يعني
الضفه اليسرى من نهر دنبرو باتجاه كل
الاراضي وصولا الى النهايات عند بحر ازوف
وايضا ااه الاسود
هي عمليه مزعجه عمليه مربكه للقوات
العسكريه في المعنويات في العتاب وفي
اعاده الانتشار ليوم استرداد استرداد
خرسان امر يحتم على القوات الاكرانيه اولا
تامين الامن العاملان كما يقال يعني تنظيف
المنطقه غرب او الضفه الغربيه اللي نهر
النيبرو وهذا امر يتطلب وقت اليوم سوف
يتاثر كل الحركات العسكريه الروسيه في
الضفه الشرقيه لنهر النيبرو بما يملك
الجيش الاوكراني من سلاح على سبيل المثال
تم اختيار همم عاصمه مؤقته بعيده 200
كيلومتر وهذا امر طبيعي على سبيل المثال
الهاي مارس يطال 80 كيلو متر فاذا كل تجمع
عسكري كل تجمع مهم كل مركز ثقل اساسي
عسكري سيكون على الاقل بعيدا 80 كيلو متر
او اكثر وهذا يؤمر يؤثر وعمليات العسكريه
الروسيه ما رايك فيما يقوله الروس سيد
عميد يسحنا بان ما جرى هو فقط اعاده تموضع
او اعاده انتشار
عبد الصمد اذا نتذكر الانسحاب من
الليسيشنزك الاوكراني كان لهدف تكتي
للاحتفاظ بالقوه وانقاذ هذه القوه لمرحله
لاحقه ناجحه اليوم الانسحاب الروسي ليس
تكتيكي انه عملاني اوبريشن كما يقال قد
يؤثر على المستوى والاستراتيجي هم محقون
لان المعركه كانت خاسره ولكن يبقى ما هو
المرحله القادمه كيف سيقاتل وكيف سيحقق
بدل معين في المرحله القادمه الجيش الروسي
من خلال معطيات الموجوده لديك من خلال
المتابعه
لنوع همم المعدات والوحدات والتجهيزات
الموجوده لدى الجانب الروسي في همم مقاطعه
خرسهم في مناطق الموجودون فيها هل
بامكانهم تقديم دفاعات قويه لاي هجوم مضاد
سياتي من الجانب الاوكراني
سلمى الهجوم لن ياتي حتما من عبر نهر
النيبرو بعد تدمير كل الجسور وهو عائق كان
امام القوات الروسيه ايضا قد ياتي الهدف
والهجوم من مكان اخر يجب ان ننظر اذا ماذا
سيحدث في بخموت ماذا سيحدث في اسباطوف
وكريمينا والاهم سلمان قد يحدث شيء في ذا
فروجيا لانه زفروجه القوات الاوكرانيه
موجوده غرب انهار او شرق النهر قادره على
النزول جنوبا باتجاه باتجاه مليتوبول يعني
من ينظر الى الخارطه يعرف اهميه المدينه
مليتوبول هي تذهب باتجاه ازوف باتجاه
خيرسون وبتجاه دوم بس هذا امر مهم جدا
وهنا سيكون التركيز الروسي على الدفاعات
في هذه المنطقه ذلك ان رؤوس يركزون الان
على الحفاظ على مكتسبات ما يسمونه
مكتسباتهم الميدانيه وانهم لن يتقدموا
اكثر
عبد الصمد تاريخيا بالعقل الروسي والعقيده
الروسيه تقول ان الدفاع هو مرحله مؤقته
للاستعداد للهجوم ياتي عامل الشتاء ياتي
الاسلحه ال ال ال الايرانيه بترو تشيب ذهب
الى ايران الاستعداد والتدريب لنعرف ما
المرحله القادمه اللهم الا اذا حصل شيء ما
بالحسبان استعمال سلاح غير تقليدي كما
يعني يدور الحديث
شكرا لك